good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast today is our final
episode before our official hiatus while
we go on vacation except I'm working
half the time but you know what the
hustle never sleeps oh my god I hate
when people say that but it's so true
it's so true I do intend to sleep next
week and I'm so excited I actually like
whenever I get I'm like an invocation
and then actually I'd like a real
vacation I'm like this looking sucks I
want to go back to like being on the
highway with my sister stitch so I'm
looking forward to we're taking two
weeks off so I have a full week of work
and then a full week of chill oh that's
good that's pretty yeah perfect balance
you don't mean I'm all about balance I'm
on roids now and I'm [ __ ] balanced I
have two whole weeks and [ __ ] I was just
thinking I can tell you how these words
are [ __ ] with me like I think I went
to the doctor yesterday for a checkup
[ __ ] I'm really recovering nicely she
said the roids well [ __ ] you up I'm like
ductile I know they're gonna [ __ ] me up
and she's like you they'll give you
trouble sleeping I'm like yeah I know
but now I'm like really aware of the
trouble sleeping
like I was in my bed and I fell asleep
for the night and I woke up like ready
for the morning and like it was still
dark outside and I could to force myself
to go back to sleep but also they say it
helps your skinny glove so who am I to
judge that sounds nice I haven't been
sleeping all either but all of that will
be a thing of the past but I just seems
crazy last night I got you in the
morning I watched the first episode of
Friends because I never watched it and I
want a weird flex yeah I know so random
how weird is it oh my god it's so we're
doing the relationships it's also just
like the relationships between the cast
members are not that like set yet and
it's super awkward and like really
scripted I've actually been getting into
curb and I was like I'm always like in
and out of curb I don't think I've ever
watched a curb from beginning to end and
you just like not appreciate the humor
in it but now I was like a comedian
myself I like fully understand how Larry
David is like truly the comedic genius
of our lifetime oh it's the best show
ever and now I'm getting up to like the
very end where they do the Seinfeld
reboot and it's just like it's so funny
but I said this yesterday there is
always one character that ruins a show
it's like they're the protagonists they
make bad decisions and for me it's
[ __ ] Cheryl and I can't [ __ ] stand
her and Jim she's married to RFK jr. no
I didn't know that was googling her
afterwards cuz it's like she had this
huge part she was also in probably one
of the greatest movies of our generation
RV
with Robin Williams and Jojo oh she was
probably in one of the greatest shows
that of course was canceled Suburgatory
right and then she would stop twerking
and it's like Oh cuz she married a
Kennedy like it made sense you know yeah
already Kennedy like you wouldn't I
would never see you again no but like
maybe for curb I show up ya know it's
just so weird she's just the worst most
annoying character sighs she doesn't get
Larry at all you know Ted why are they
married right how did they get married
yeah set them up no totally uh it's a
great show
last night except I'm sorry I can't
watch it with Ben because you're gonna
have to be in my mic like he like less
and nothing but when he laughs at curb
it's like yeah like so [ __ ] loud in
my ear like I'm gonna go deaf like I
can't watch it I don't want it to be
funny because they don't want Ben to
laugh oh my god that's torture I watched
the worst movie ever last night like I
just have this thing where I'm at MIT I
will only watch garbage no it's like oh
this is like award-winning acclaim
everyone's talking about it no this
movie with Noah sent any oh that like
fell into the garbage can
sure what movie yeah no no it never
heard of it because it's a garbage movie
is called swiped and it was trap a
Netflix original no it was just like a
garbage can original okay my favorite I
knew it so I actually didn't even finish
it because it didn't need to be finished
but it's like and I'm still watching
love island though it's the worst show
I've ever seen really heard negative
things about the American version but
it's like I enjoy watching garbage maybe
because I don't have to pay attention
and I don't feel bad about being on my
phone yeah things happening but it has
to stop it just takes so much effort to
get into something challenging they just
don't want to challenge myself I
understand so I don't know I need to
really I need to do better I mean I have
been my in use of time in an emotional
television little ever since I finished
Desperate Housewives like I literally
haven't been able to recover or find a
show that makes me so happy
keeps me engaged keeps me off my phone
Ben loves it too like really the plot is
like there I have not been able to
recover since it's like three watch Ugly
Betty oh that's a good one that's a
great one I have we watched it once but
like I need to rewatch it since the
rewatch we watch it together like in
high school and I haven't really watched
it since it was on TV I mean it's a
[ __ ] great television show there's so
many great things about Ugly Betty
obviously Betty and her family are
hilarious but Marc and Amanda
captioners Blanda everything oh sorry
Vanessa Williams have it all truly
genius Rebecca Romijn Jerry O'Connell
like of course it's a show it's actually
a great call Michael what is it on
probably who Lulu but you can also if
it's not anywhere you can like buy it on
iTunes if you yeah yeah okay oh I like
that movie that's a good weekend
activity from wha that's a great
suggestion yeah I just need to like
start just spending my time better when
I'm watching TV can you believe that
like there was a time where you could
put a show on the air called Ugly Betty
like you could never do that these days
I don't know could because it was like
turning it on its head she was such an
icon right like she was so beautiful for
being so ugly you know when she was the
star of a show and she was ugly and more
poncho and glasses but it's like she
wasn't even ugly they just made her ugly
you don't I mean look at Ferrara's
beautiful no but that was why you can
call her right right I guess you can put
like an actually ugly person behind me
yeah I think it could work so but you'll
see when you read watching the
commenters are saying that Ugly Betty is
on Netflix so for that why I'm excited
it is there's no way there's we're gonna
say I would have seen it that's what
people are saying we'll see about that
in fact check on that yeah yeah if only
we had a fact checker okay well luckily
for you guys you have a great show for
you today although the news sucks the
news sucks but I've said a lot of
thoughts you know because a lot has
happened to me I've been like listening
to just like lots of people's
conversations and having thoughts about
it and it can't wait till we talk about
the heat stroke because I happened to be
on the way when the heat wave whatever
yeah and the way here today okay I'll
wait I'll wait we'll get into it um no
Marcus it's on Hulu yeah okay
except you can't download offline from
Hulu that was the problem I have with
Hulu you know what I was thinking last
night as I was going through every
streaming sure I looked at everything on
HBO Netflix Hulu Amazon Prime I was like
we've never had more streaming services
yet less things to watch content you
know like I don't like Suzy's coming out
with one there's like Warner Brothers
whatever there's so many new streaming
services that are being built still
gonna mean nothing to watch and then I
feel like I find random shows that I
like on random streaming services and
then I never hear about them again like
what the [ __ ] happened to read out I
love that show do get cancelled is there
another season
there definitely another scene it was
over no it was over I think it was like
a short story that had to be told I
think this
was over but like I fell in love with
don't trust the B in apartment 23 on
Netflix never to be heard from again and
to be taken off of Netflix and to be
taken off of that place the best show of
I think our generation
I agreed okay I don't agree but I hear
you and I respect your decision to have
a wrong opinion but have you ever seen
it yeah it's like a fine show it's a
little annoying like hilarious and that
they're all hazel Jun yeah but she plays
hazel and Gossip Girl oh she's so
[ __ ] annoying like I can't get past
her like face yeah she's pretty annoying
Gemma Walker is that her name yeah
annoying dreama Sriman well since it
only has been 10 minutes what we do have
a lot of ground to cover today I think
we're ready I think we're ready I feel
ready you know and through these stories
we can use it as a vessel to talk about
ourselves yeah of course I mean at the
end of the day that's what the toast is
like we put together this show just so
we could have a platform to talk about
ourselves yeah so let's get to it
here are the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast today's
episode is brought to you by purple if
you're struggling to get a good night's
sleep you've got to try purple mattress
Purple's company history the founders of
purple are two brothers hopefully
they're hot and single who have been do
that I make the same joke every time
we've been developing cushioning
technology for 30 years on things like
medical beds and wheelchairs and in 2016
they finally decided to use their
patented comfort technology to create
purple the world's most scientific
mattress the mattress will probably feel
different than anything you've ever
experienced because it uses brand-new
material that was developed by an actual
rocket scientist it's not like the
memory foam we are used to the purple
mattress feels very unique because it
both is firm and soft at the same time
which is perfect for Ben and I because
when me and then we're moving into an
apartment together we literally could
not agree on a bed because he wants like
something hard to align this back and
I'm like now I just wanted to fall to
fall asleep on a puffy bed of clouds so
the purple mattress has really been
perfect for us they have a hundred night
risk free trial if you're not fully
satisfied you can return your mattress
for a full refund which is crazy backed
by a 10-year warranty free shipping and
returns and a free in-home setup an old
mattress removal that is where you get
your money because like try to move a
mattress out of an apartment like you
might as well just literally go to
SoulCycle you're going to love purple
and right now our listeners will get a
free purple pillow with the purchase of
their mattress that's in addition to the
great free gifts they'll get offering
site-wide text toast to eight four eight
eight eight the only way to get this
free pillow is to Tex toast TOA st to
eight
four eight eight eight that's toas t28
for a love it by the way well before we
jump in because you know anything to not
yeah a few housekeeping announcement and
I just wanted to clarify with you on the
next two weeks so I'm gone for two weeks
no shows for two weeks I know you guys
we're gonna try and make the second week
work I don't know I think so
it doesn't no no but like if we're
feeling like we have to come back out
there and we have the time then yeah
okay
cool and we have a patron episode up
from yesterday that is blind reveals
from July fourth from aunty Anderson's
and it's a really great episode and we
have another episode going up today just
a general Q&A since we have so many new
projects in the works I just feel like
everyone's like dying to know if we're
in the comments as I guess Claudia I'm
speed no [ __ ] alone bro it's okay yeah
I can't stop freaking talking she's
writing that I'm writing it up I feel
like a [ __ ] high school quarterback
er I feel like smash Williams writing up
before a big game and ready to get my
scholarship taken away you know yeah
that's so much times you said ya better
watch it your scholarship fellowship is
like literally with an arm surge but I'm
gonna lose it because ya know like smash
Williams had a great [ __ ] mom and she
raised him right
no you're like Lance Armstrong like
you're about to lose it all
totally ed the testicle okay first story
Taylor Swift I'm sorry just took me to
Ayesha curry it's like the the interwebs
just want me to talk about her and her
like missus like a baby we know she
misspoke about like it's such a stupid
even though Adams Taylor Swift in more
stars embrace their inner feline in
first cats trailer okay the trailer for
cats which is coming out in December has
been released and they've answered the
age-old question of are we gonna use
cats or people we're using both yeah
everyone looks freaky as [ __ ] it's a
really freaky trailer and it has been
released to mixed reviews well because
from my understanding I mean I let's see
I've said you see anything Taylor
stripped is it and I really do love like
a live-action remake of like a tale as
old as time but I'm not particularly
understanding what cats is and I know
that it's a musical it's the
longest-running musical ever on Broadway
and I thought that it was just like
because it's the longest running musical
on Broadway ever it has to be great
right but it's known to be like Andrew
Lloyd Webber's like most
ominous weird piece of work that never
really makes any sense it's about a
gaggle of cats who just aren't
introducing themselves yeah yeah no no
it's about a gaggle of cats who are like
a part of this crew they're like the
jumbly crew and they spend the entire
night figuring out which one of the cats
is gonna ascend to like this next layer
to get their new life because cats have
new lives which is so dumb and so stupid
and even if I liked cats like cats the
animal like I would not think this is
cute
but I just have I don't think Taylor
Smith and James Corden an interest elbow
but but their names rebel Wilson let me
be rebel Wilson would put their names on
something that's Josh you know rebel
Wilson has put her name on system and I
think my quality cuz they're like acting
like cats
oh I'm sorry could you do that again on
off the camera like acting like that's
like they really didn't get the part I
thought that was crazy that they
literally have to like become Cassie
Taylor Swift shoes she's ready like
literally like six year old like tap
shoes yes kidnapped tap shoes she looks
so cute check she looks very pretty
um she looks like her cats oh this is a
dream role for her but for every pretty
dress Elba and Judi Dench I'm not seeing
it I'm not seeing it but I'm seeing it
for James Corden because he actually
like looks like a cat in real life too
right and he's the only one who didn't
have to like look like a weird cat like
he's old enough to put on a costume
right so did you finish
kimmy schmitt season okay so you know
the whole cat storyline where the show
cats is really anyone who wants to be in
it you just have to have a breath valium
and then you introduce yourself and I'm
pretty sure like cats is just sit play
where they're all the cats are
introducing them so no so that's like a
running joke people are saying now on
Twitter like because from kitty bit when
from Kenny Schmidt yeah but if some
really what this plays that you know
maybe like the at the end of the day
someone's ascending like it's [ __ ]
Riverdale okay we'll say way that they
get there through an introduction we'll
see we'll see honestly I do not have
high hopes this trailer looks [ __ ]
weird it's like CGI is out of control
and just because you can doesn't mean
you should but they really built out
because I watched it behind the scenes
thing they built the set to be so
oversized it's not CGI in the sense that
like if there's a chair there supposed
to be the size of a cat so they made
this huge [ __ ] chair so Taylor Swift
looks like a cat's eyes
human next to a chair I think that's
just no but definitely the technology
that they're using a face for their
faces and their bodies are the same that
they use on the Beast and Beauty and the
Beast I'm just saying how it's cool that
the set is not CGI it's like actually
oversized built furniture that that's
fine that's cool I'm just think it's
cool I mean that's like when they made
the little town in greatest showmen they
made like a ant sized town and then they
panned over it to look like New York
City cool yes in the 1800s what is this
a town for ants it was yes yes yes it is
actually um okay I know you guys will be
seeing it I'll probably see you to
Jennifer Hudson's rendition of memory
sounds like the only saving grace okay
me on the count of three when you hear
the song memory what we think of three
two one School of Rock okay like [ __ ]
Miranda Cosgrove icon honestly weird
cause I'm a going to say she's a looking
icon did you see what I think this
Photoshop scenes pose maybe yesterday
icarly walked Sasori to rock and run so
true like in a lot of ways miranda
cosgrove has set the stage for
influencers for actresses for for just
like for everyone you know yeah and I
don't think she gets nearly enough
credit for the videos she posts of
herself singing on it sir well we give
her credit here at this show but I agree
like look society society really this
show was literally all about giving
credit to like people who like don't get
it yeah people who have been Matthew
koma right we literally like she
changing name of the show to like get
credit
no it's justice it's just yet insert
someone and just yeah and we've always
been that oh wait that's a true we're
like really see true to our broad
message yeah I mean really annoying
today you guys can get miranda cosgrove
on this show easily I think we could - I
think we could - which doesn't say a lot
about the stature of this show but I
don't care cuz I [ __ ] with miranda
cosgrove
[Music]
I also think of Kant viga that was like
one of our songs yeah we had to like
learn a lot of old-school songs like I'd
have her at danger teacher but I'm just
gonna glaze over so on
what does it truly make that me take
that my ring back tone I say it's just
you saying song yeah you'll pick up
really likes you know you should make
toast my new single that comes out
August 2nd your new ringing back tongue
I'm gonna make it my ringtone I thought
that'd be cute right how are you gonna
premiere it um well so it's August 2nd
oh so it just goes on Spotify yeah well
it'd have to come out on a Friday
because all new music comes out on
Friday so beyond I just got a PI on
Friday do we have a show Friday we're
back Monday we're back Monday okay so
we'll party it up all weekend and maybe
I'll have like a like a launch party
I believe launch parties for like
intangible things do you know no mean
yeah but no a song is the thing I think
when people have launch parties for
things that haven't launched or for
things that take zero dollars to launch
yeah right or like people on reality
shows are always throwing launch parties
just cuz like they need a party to go to
to film at that's fine when Ramona had a
skincare party unless you'd given
formula that's fine but then the purpose
of the party is that create buzz yeah
but when you have like a party for
something and you're not filming it and
it costs $0 time oh you're talking about
two lymphocytic but I won't say you know
what I'm talking about of course this is
like you talk about this this thing I
can cross man no truly
okay anyways next up in today's thin
news LuAnn de Lesseps launches feeling
Giovanni IV drip what money can't buy
the cross but it can buy you a feeling
Giovanni drip feeling Java Real
Housewives of New York City star LuAnn
de Lesseps is partnered with IV drips to
create her own custom intravenous
therapy formula infused with vitamins
and minerals to help promote health and
hydration I'm sorry has learned IV
stands for intravenous I guess so I
thought it was like internal vessel the
intermediate yeah oh I guess that is the
exact same thing yeah okay quote it's
the perfect recharge and reset button
after a workout especially in this
record-setting heat wave which will be a
great segue to our next story this
formula changes everything the song is
about channels every
the song is about youth energy Chanel's
and just an overall sense of positivity
I'm like I actually really do love
Luann's music but feeling Giovanni is
not it it is not a good song but did you
hear that DJ Pauly D is remix in it well
Jax just really the beauty of watchstrap
inside like two people come on they get
married Jenny McCarthy Donnie Wahlberg
Jimmy we'll come on they make a smash
hit
Pauly D LuAnn de Lesseps so here for
that collaboration but it's just like
the word Giovanni and I'd like the
Dorinda said it in the in the reunion
she's like we're not making money off of
this like let's stop looking for running
this $400 dress brand like yeah it's
annoying it's and I don't like it I'm
not here for the word Giovanni well when
Ramona was on watch what happens like
the other night and Andy asked her about
the song she was like I'm over it and
and he was like what the song just can't
she's like no I'm over Giovanni like
yeah it's and I'm over it it's not from
at the time it was the funniest thing
ever and when it was like we were all
making fun of Geron des like lack of
self-awareness that she was saying
Giovanni all the time like it was funny
but now it's like so overtly annoying
and stupid like over the song and I
don't care that just came over the
entire concept ya know it's like it's me
beaten a dead horse
let's move on Tunisia song came out and
then a horse was already dead
yeah so that's why I yes I agree with
Ramona I am over it yeah when I was cute
I watched Upton's live she really was I
mean she looked fantastic and she was
just being super Potts but she is such a
problem because that romper was self and
then when she stood up after sitting for
watched up and slide for 45 minutes all
the Getty photos
she's so many wrinkles near her thighs
it sucks and like Joey is just like
looking perfect that's annoying and she
had any times like steam her crotch she
was being really nice to do read and I
feel like sometimes she can be like
[ __ ] yes you guys especially to like
newer cast but I think she definitely
felt like a little threatened in the
sense like Joey just like showed the
[ __ ] up but I don't feel like she
compares herself to her to read also I
want to talk about
vote obviously gonna talk about the
reunion but I just loved what Ramona
said about feeling herself and that like
she's 15 to 20 years older than a lot of
the girls as most of the women and like
she looks just as great as any of them
and she's gonna show it off I just I
think she's doing so much for older
women no I actually couldn't agree more
and I want to save what I have to say
but like I thought everyone was coming
for her in a lot of ways a little
unfairly especially when it came to that
like it's actually admirable the
competence she has at any age especially
being the oldest woman on the show the
oldest woman in the franchise
looking better than half of them like I
really respect her so much and like I
don't think it's annoying there's so
many things that she does that are
annoying that's not one of them no
that's not one of them and we've also
seen her like yo-yo she's looks better
she's looking much she's gained weight
and like now she's older than she's ever
been and she looks better than Giovanni
like that's it
yeah um anyways I love a good IV drip
well it's so weird how do you do a
collaborative like I've heard of you
know influencers Desperate Housewives
doing all types of collabs you know we
got shoes we got makeup I've never heard
of an IV collabed well yeah what does
she put like well you have to love it
let it go for the in-person procedure at
the IV drip lounge in Brooklyn oh so no
one's gonna go it's in Brooklyn yeah so
it's a she gonna be there what's special
about it I don't know you can feel like
Giovanni when you get it it's incredibly
oh my god excuse me it's stupid
yes like I just want a regular try it I
don't even like those strips I get so
bruised my poor veins everyone tells me
everyone tells me my things are so hard
to find but probably not now because I'm
writing they're probably just like
you're so vascular thank you should you
get what now usually the neck just pop
it out
I'm usually nurses have a very hard time
finding my veins cuz I'm so small and
frail it's just like my small frame that
looks like so worried about me like
where my veins I have the opposite
problem use your veiny as though you can
see my veins from a mile away oh my god
oh my god you know me and Margaret us
covered yesterday you're gonna be so
upset speaking of veiny MJ Kardashian
did you buy the brush for the kick in it
uh I don't think I was able to get it
but I got a brush from my patrick tah so
I have a brush okay I do not eat I when
I went on the k'kaw Beauty Foundation
leg crap website I was like I was on
time and it could have gotten a brush I
just thought one of the two items I
bought would come with a brush oh you
know at the same mistake Jim that you
had to get the brush and I put it in my
cart any I couldn't even get it thanks
for the heads-up I think I don't know I
haven't used my stuff yet I'm gonna get
spray tan today so very unfair I'm so
obsessed so now I'm gonna fight yeah I
don't know how I'm gonna play maybe then
they'll have to wait for the next store
you just go to like blue mercury and get
a body brush or something
I know but it's like I want the one made
for this magnet formula it's like
there's never been a body foundation
before like like this that actually you
could probably go to Mac and get one
body foundation ok back yeah ok so maybe
so they probably have good brushes so
they test on that at all so I know the
brushes - yeah it's like a company-wide
thing I think ok now there's my socks
today like I like I have this cute
outfit it's like my [ __ ] socks like
protruding out like a six year old do
you know what I mean yeah no that's
definitely forgot me dressed you know
yeah what I like your dress where's it
from
thank you so much it is um I got these
two brands confused oh this one's show
me your room oh and it's nice and
stretchy and I respect the hell out show
me of me because they've up to
extra-large like none of those revolver
heads do you extra larger isn't
revolutionary [ __ ] until you're extra
large you know - how revolutionary it is
literally all the time first of all I go
and revolve and I start shopping and I'm
like you know let me refine I need to
ever goes up to excel yeah literally it
goes from 10,000 items I swear to got to
4,000 items but you still a lot but you
know what it's not enough then every
time I go I find something I like
finally extra-large it's either sold out
or its last one left it's like how does
it always the last one left I don't know
it always gets me to buy it though yeah
of course like oh my god I need this all
the other fat girls have it no I just
think I'm having it's like socks
problems lately because I'm not wearing
my bombas you're not wearing your mama's
and it shows because how often do you
think about your socks if you're like I
used to be not much but I recent
discovered socks that change the way I
think about socks forever
they're called Thomas they are
technically according to science they
are the most comfortable socks in the
history of feet and I can come I can
support that theory because I have worn
them and I'm not wearing them today and
I'm not [ __ ] comfortable and my feet
are really sweaty no and like wearing
improper socks can be super detrimental
to your toenails Oh children also like
to your outfit and your morale like I
feel like a slob chain with my ugly like
dirty like that once were white socks
bama's are the most comfortable socks in
the history of feet they're made from
super soft natural cotton and every pair
comes with arch support a seamless toe
and a cushioned foot bend that's comfy
but not too thick with many colors
patterns lainson styles bombas look
great in the gym the office and out of -
out on the town bombas are what feet
daydream about and for every bombas
purchase you make bombas donates a pair
to someone in need which is about the
best part of the entire brand but i
can't just talk about the ark support
because i
theory that I have flat feet I do I
can't stand on my feet for like more
than 15 minutes that like getting tired
and like painful maybe that's just like
me being fat and out of shape but also
like maybe I show us your CH I'm wearing
a lot of so I'm gonna see a flat foot by
your bum bus at mom fuzzy it counts I'm
in the middle of something
I'm by your bombas at bombas calm slash
toast today I get 20% off your first
purchase
that's B om ba s.com slash toast for 20%
off bombas calm slash toast surely one
of the brands that I had heard about but
never thought about using until they
partnered with the toast and now can't
get over it can't get over it I
seriously love them someone wrote the
funniest thing socks in a heatwave on
roids oh my god Claudia so true in my
case
also Spanx today cuz my address Wow I
just felt compelled to look really cute
today cuz this episode is gonna be the
last episode for a while so if anyone's
like missing the toaster like we watch
this episode and they're like see any
writing and stuff and they hate so I
just wanted to give them a cute like
last look and now them look at myself on
camera like I look super shiny around
today it's like the ROI it's like really
busting out me so like I'm upset but
like any were like I like you well yeah
you'll have to take some pictures of me
afterwards you do the cute I had the
same thought where it's like oh I was
maybe gonna wear workout clothes and
then I was like no this is gonna be the
last one on the YouTube channel for a
while um and then I came up with this
they see me roid and say hey and I'm
like I'm loving the ROI place you're
like a-rod totally okay third story the
Jewish was requested by you okay heat
wave to hit two-thirds of the u.s.
here's what to expect dangerously hot
temperatures are predicted from Oklahoma
to New England
here's the forecast with some tips on
staying safe dangerously high
temperatures are expected to spread
across the central and eastern United
States on Wednesday through the weekend
with temperatures soaring above a
hundred degrees Fahrenheit in the
hardest hit places the National Weather
Service is warned even and even when the
Sun dips below the horizon
temperatures in many places are expected
to remain in the 80s the hottest part of
the country smack dab in the middle
those flyovers days okay whatever this
is what I want to talk about was on my
way here the
ever had the radio on and they had an
interview live phone interview with Bill
DeBlasio and it's like well you never
hear from the mayor because he's always
before 10 a.m. yeah like he's always
like vacationing and like campaigning
for a presidential campaign he's not he
could be doing those things and be on
the phone but he's like never in New
York you never hear from him and it's
like the country was in crisis like I
mean the state was in crisis we had a
blackout and he was in Iowa like
literally he's and I just like could've
believed I was like hearing from in life
and he said someone that truly liked the
craziest things I was literally writing
them down because I had to tell you how
crazy it was first he was like he was
warning everyone about the heatwave and
how the blackout last week he doesn't
think was related to the heat but it
could be so everyone charge your phones
in case there's another blackout
I saw there's like because it's gonna be
so hot this weekend there could be
another blackout I'm sorry we've never
been able to predict like if you know
the blackouts gonna happen it's not
gonna happen it's okay you don't just
see country thing was that they were
talking so much about the heat wave the
heat wave the heat wave he was saying
things as crazy as like that's how
important it is to stay cool they have
like cooling centers at local libraries
and like great things that the the
city's providing and if you feel faint
you know drink water call 9-1-1
absolutely said and then he had the
audacity to talk about how government
buildings and corporate office buildings
are too cold and they are now beat an
executive order to be 78 degrees I don't
know
everyone's gonna be feeling faint
calling 9-1-1 you talk about the [ __ ]
heatwave and you're ordering corporate
buildings down a 78 degrees gust of wind
when you open the door but also it's
gonna be the weekend people corporate
buildings aren't working and like what
just apples and oranges my friend
Chuckie
it was the most ludicrous interview I've
ever heard in my life and like I know
like not a lot of people who know who
Bill DeBlasio is because if you don't
live in New York he hasn't rode your
life yet but he's coming for you he's
trying to eat is coming for your life to
ruin it and like I'm really not a
political person I'm not and I'm not
swaying on any tide you can boat for
Chile whoever you want like please don't
vote for Bill DeBlasio I could not have
four more years of bill like he is just
such a torturer I like the city is in
shambles and it's so hot and now it's 70
degrees everywhere like please so what
are you guys gonna do this weekend are
your [ __ ] inside oh well because we meet
my friends I didn't know there's a heat
wave we heard those 100 degrees here go
to my friends pool on a roof oh that's
smart so that's awesome yeah we're gonna
make a day of it but maybe some people
only go outside
gonna be inside all day like Theo is a
precious chef he can't handle it it was
technically a job but it's not really
like outdoorsy we will be staying inside
with air conditioning and we're gonna be
watching Ugly Betty and I'm really
looking forward I know I say this like
every six months I got a weekend at home
and I'm like I'm so bored after the
first five minutes that's not gonna
happen to me today
sure it's not sure well do any are an
interesting factoid sure because extreme
heat can kill last year 108 people died
from extreme heat yes I know that's why
his 30 who died from cold that's why he
said to call 9-1-1 because young kids
and old like senior citizens really
connect heatstroke and it can be very
dangerous so I'm not like me infront of
that I just felt like the way he was
talking about like so dire and but he's
also like making other buildings cooler
I mean more warmer
well um because you know there's a war
on air-conditioning now that the [ __ ]
New York Times started yes like for
people who work in corporate office
buildings apparently when it gets really
hot the building's generate so much
air-conditioning that the people are
freezing and it's like an attack on
millennial women somehow which I don't
understand but I just want to say like I
love that we're progressing as a as a
generation like sometimes like I'm
watching friends and I'm like I can't
believe that you used to be able to say
things like that and I really like that
we're like in this new age of you know
where everyone's being protected and
everyone's equal but like please stay
away from air conditioning like it
didn't do anything to you and like it
needs to stay ya know I remember working
in a corporate office it was always cold
but you just think had a blanket and a
cardigan it makes it look fun you like
ride yourself up at work go to sleep
there must be like a reason as to why
they can't just I've read somewhere that
it's like through women's wear shorter
skirts and it's like that's not it like
it's not always what skirts yeah well
you know what this is a great segue into
our next story which sort of touches on
this you know what are these things
called seesaw
oh sorry one more thing bills Blasio
said it's like he's a [ __ ] mayor of
Newark he doesn't know why the blackout
happened last week he said and I spoken
with the president of cada and you know
a bunch times like he won't tell me
what's not no way no one [ __ ]
respects you literally the president
have cut out literally won't tell you
what happened
no Cuomo is saying like to Con Ed like
figure it out or you're fired
you know what we're never tired every
time I'm hearing about Governor Cuomo
he's been very rational and I should say
I respect the hell out of Governor Cuomo
and is he the one who dates women from
the Food Network no that's why we play
no no no no you know what I'm talking
about Sandra Lee centrally Sandra Lee
boyfriend no but I think she
married to Governor Cuomo Andrew Cuomo
is very marry me wait the one who was
like the tiny one on Leblond at home
essentially oh my god I loved her
partner is Andrew Cuomo still Wow
they're in the partnership they're not
that she's her domestic partner
interested since 2005 oh I get them
confused with the blonde District
Attorney from SVU being married to Bobby
Flay that is so confusing
yeah because want something oka life no
and one place the real-life version yeah
up no [ __ ]
their gender switching that is so funny
Wow that is so funny good for Governor
Cuomo's a my homemade he's must be
living the life okay back to the seesaw
or I guess the word is the pendulum of
political correctness a new story that I
thought was particularly interesting and
I want to get your thoughts gendered
language like manhole will soon be
banned from Berkeley city codes soon
there will be no manholes in the City of
Berkeley California what other words
like that are there there will also be
no Chairman no man power no policemen or
no police women no that doesn't mean a
whole city will be without committee
leaders and law enforcement it means
that the words that imply a gender
preference will be removed from the
city's code and replaced with
gender-neutral turns according a
recently adopted ordinance the city
voted Tuesday night to replace gender
terms in its municipal codes like
manhole and manpower with gender neutral
ones like maintenance whole and instead
of manpower human effort
I need Berkeley's [ __ ] wild and out
okay so are we gonna change horsepower
soon too because that's like offensive
today like zebras okay but like you know
what it's like I am someone who is very
you know comfortable and stable in my
gender and my sexuality and I don't feel
like this really applies to me because
this is more for people who don't
identify as man woman and so it's not my
issue to speak on but if it was I would
say that this is a little extreme it's
just a little but again it's not my
issue like you know I always compare
it's like okay let's say it was like Jew
power you know it's like no we got to
change a show you know like you know you
know what if you're the Jew that
wouldn't offend the Jew it would offend
like other religions like why are the
Jews power right I guess that's true I
don't know what scenario this would like
be my problem but it's not so I just I
will see how it goes
yeah we'll see how it goes I mean he
said the councilmember Buerkle civil
council member said there's power in
language and this is a small move but it
matters it is a small move does it
matter I don't know so I don't put in a
great scheme of the gender neutrality
movement if changing the world the word
manhole like really will make a
difference if I'm taking that dead
seriously like there are many things
that like look I think well I feel like
there's two it's $2 billion poor of it
Billy Porter wearing a gown to the Met
Gala like that is a huge step for the
judgment to the Oscars whatever like
that is a huge step for the gender
neutral movement like change the word
manhole like I don't know if it has the
same impact well I feel like change the
word manhole and then changing
placements these women it's two totally
separate things like I feel like the man
or man power represents that men are
powerful but then policemen please women
there might be a police officer who
doesn't identify as either of those you
know so right and so I wonder what the
new term for please people will be
police people maybe or a police officer
yeah oh yeah but we've always had police
officer so are they just banning
policeman police woman yeah Berkeley
it's like this microcosm or they just
like do crazy [ __ ] and like if it works
like the other the rest of the world
like applies to it and then like if it
doesn't like we were talking I can never
happened yeah it's like 1989 the student
riots I learned about them
OSR net album tell us what it was at
night I'm sorry was 1969 when we went to
the moon 50 years ago tomorrow
we went to people are like all shook up
over the 50th anniversary of the moon
landing that and Ignatz is gonna be live
tweeting the whole thing like as if they
had twitter and i suppose you guys saw
when they do that that's cool I love
that yeah oh my god it's so funny I was
watching an old episode I think I told
this story recently like I was watching
an old episode of the breath and we were
talking about like how some country
orbited the moon it was like a story of
like a big deal for some country maybe
was America I don't know a small step
for mankind whatever like everyone was
like watching it and talking about it
and I literally said these words I was
like I can't imagine being a big enough
loser that I would like literally watch
like another country
like moon like bland on the moon and
like a literary week ago I watch the
entire like is there a live stream and
I'm just like so invested in all of elon
musk's work so it's really crazy how
like a year can change Oh a year can
change you
I'm locust [ __ ] now totes right I'm
writing it up - yeah that helps with the
woken is you know when the moon landed
when we landed on the moon 50 years ago
it was the most watched television
telecast of all time at the time people
watching in the streets people watching
everywhere wow what is the most watched
talk that's of all time now like the
Superbowl what is it considered a
telecast now that oh I guess the
telecast as worldwide here Super Bowl is
just America let's google it
most-watched elekid it's like a royal
wedding or maybe like some soccer thing
oh the 2008 Olympics Opening Ceremony
was that one no that wasn't London maybe
that was a thens and I feel like the
numbers are going down because less and
less people are watching TV but there
are still big moments like that oh no
the 2008 was that Beijing did you watch
that what 2008 was a sump pit was
Beijing a Summer Olympics I don't know I
[ __ ] love the Olympics was summer
love next summer in Tokyo oh my god 2008
we were at Seneca actually I don't even
ever want to go to the Olympics I love
watching them for my house so buried
going home I remember like being either
at camp and like watching them like in
the dining hall or like being like
working over the summer and my
internships like running home to watch
to like the time difference it would be
on like I really loved watching every
mom I never want to go to-- it's the
perfect baby you see anything it's a
perfectly decent job and there's a
million channels there's so many things
going on how do you choose what to go to
we're at home we just flip through the
channels and I'm sure the traffic is
insane
oh yeah the traffic wait this is an
interesting list of the most so I said
but I don't know if it's true that
Krista Carlson Romano is making a new
music video with that song in honor of
the 50th anniversary like if that's true
I would literally die and come back to
life Andrey Roy it up well she has been
very in tune with what's necessary
lately and she has a web show and like
if this is this makes complete sense
because it would be a complete missed
opportunity for her and like she knows
that that is her [ __ ] cross to bear
right that we went to the moon in 1969
no and if she doesn't like you a little
bit if she doesn't remake this music
video she will literally be letting down
an entire generation of men women
children and all in between I just have
to go back to what I was saying about
those stood
right and get the year right because it
was like a big movement in the world and
it was 1989 so much happened to that
slave wait there's this list of
most-watched telecasts that I'm finding
unbelievably interesting are you ready
for it yeah
number two the rescue of the Chilean
miners oh that was terrible
but as a rescue it was a happy occasion
three the spring festival gala for the
2006 FIFA World Cup final five the first
men or women
I think FIFA is men though FIFA's just
soccer really are you sure wasn't the
wait let me say a few well that was FIFA
World Cup that was yeah it was I don't
know I don't know either whatever
someone will correct us five the first
human walk on the surface of the Moon
okay
so that's still number five it's from
1969 six Aloha from Hawaii in a music
it's a music concert presented by Elvis
Presley from 1973 cool 7 the 2011
Cricket World Cup semi-final cricket 8
the wedding of Prince William and Kate
Middleton Wow 9 JFK's funeral did you
watch do you remember when that guy I
think is name was Felix it was sponsored
by Red Bull he's like a stunt man and he
like orbited the earth and jumped jumped
out do you remember that the Red Bull
thing yeah yeah and it was like so
stupid because it wasn't like a NASA
thing it was just like a prank and he
like lost consciousness halfway down and
he could have died that was a dumb thing
for us to all a cheer on he wasn't like
supported by NASA like it was literally
just a guy yeah I was being [ __ ]
stupid yeah I don't think I watch it we
love that though like people of 20 had
the camera of him like on the platform
he wasn't even in a spaceship he was
literally just like on a dock like on
the edge of the earth and just jumped
into Earth did he live again he lost
consciousness on the jump down because
it was like so fast so high right you
regain consciousness and pulled the
parachute what yeah you could watch it
on YouTube now it's like a thing that
everyone liked died for him now that I
think about it like why were we
encouraging such stupid behavior because
we're stupid we're stupid we're always
just like being influenced like being
stupid totally stupid actually find
myself being influenced like by
influencers like all the time I follow
this girl more gosh right she is so
influential and then she just
Alyssa's healthy lifestyle and I saw she
did this like really cute ad for thrive
market and she just learned what you buy
for thrive market they have I [ __ ]
love drive market but like they have
really good healthy snacks so have I
call it our puffs they have oh these
peanut butter filled pretzels those
aren't that healthy but I like them and
then they have the smart sweet so many
of them about pickles they just actually
healthy food is so expensive and you got
it off her $50 50 bucks about two
bursaries they offer the highest quality
healthy and sustainable products
available for every budget lifestyle and
geography
you can join thrive and unlike and
unlock endless savings you can shop for
thousands of the best-selling organic
foods natural products at twenty five to
fifty percent below traditional retail
prices it shouldn't be so hard first
murder your proscribe kid like you can't
be out here shopping at Trader Joe's so
the people at Trader Joe's are literally
billionaire it's like literally boom
it's crazy like organic food it just
like healthy food is so expensive it
like makes you not want to be healthy
but thrive market has higher standards
at a higher power shopping a thrive
market means supporting a select group
of brands that make the world a better
place
they sell non-gmo food snacks vitamins
supplements personal care products
eco-friendly cleaning supplies safe and
non-toxic beauty products kitchen
staples home goods organic baby foods
kid products and so much more and that's
part it's all shipped straight to your
door you can find what you're looking
for without having to look for it thrive
market offers a highly curated catalog
meaning you might only find three to
four options for each product but you
can know they're the best ingredients
the most affordable prices and safe for
you and your family
keep in mind side markets prices are
already 25 to 50 percent off and now
they're giving you an extra 25% off your
first order plus free 30-day trial many
of you will be making a grocery run this
weekend so why not give thrive market a
try and shop from your home
the link is thrive market calm / toast
thrive market calm / toast for an extra
25 percent off your first order for
prices that are already marked down 25
to 50% off I love pride market and
watching counselor snitch get all her
stuff made me love it even more I know I
got supper seal on there I am so
interested by this list of most well I
should telecast I'm just here read
enough where's Harry and Megan's um it's
not on here but maybe some of these
lists are old but one of the listen I'm
reading says that Michael Jackson's
memorial service was number 6 with 500
million estimated viewers Wow Wow ever
watched a live funeral
Aretha Franklin's house watch it live
one time YouTube clips like I'm like
ever
run home to watch something a funeral
lives no I
there's aren't that many that I guess
but like Princess Diana yeah I know
princes was his televised it must have
been I don't know
interesting very interesting and it's
interesting that nothing recent like in
the drive of you know the most people
have televisions and computers and
access and we're just not interested in
what you're putting I'm not your key
history we're not interested in your
reboots they should reboot the
moon-landing totally ok
what's up the fifth and final they've
been final um please only it's business
it's not business I wanted it to be news
news actually I guess you can make it a
business story because it's just about
the begin box office now that the Lion
King is roaring in it's really just a
movie review what are our thoughts on
the Lion King I told you today with
sparse and I want to get your thoughts I
want to get your thoughts too because I
have plans to see it this weekend
because I have heard two incredibly
different recounts from critics and I
don't like to listen to critics because
critics are the morons who gave the
movie to Lobster ninety-eight percent on
Rotten Tomatoes like I can't but I have
heard that Lion King is the most amazing
breathtaking cinematography like
achievement of our generation like it
will make you die and I've also heard
it's the most lifeless to real like you
just like awful movie like I've heard
too extreme and I can see it going that
way cuz I'm the one hand it could be
like National Geographic on roids you
know and I'm seeing the commercials and
it's like just two lines walking around
and on the other hand it could be
talking animals is this Eliza Thornberry
yeah like talking real animals I could
see it being either and so I guess it's
just really subjective like whatever
you're into so I'm excited because the
cast is just like what dreams are made
of like I'm really looking forward to
Billy Eichner like getting his moment in
in the spotlight because he is so
deserving of the world obviously Yonsei
Seth Rogen like there's just so many
gems like I'm really looking forward I'm
gonna go into it really with a positive
cuz I finally when I go in like
listening to when people say like it
always influences how I feel so I'm just
going to go in with clean eye clear eyes
full hearts and I can't [ __ ] loose
toes I'm on Brooke
today's song from the movie spirit I did
a Beyonce soul cycle this week and he
played it and it was really just so
beautifully yeah I had like other songs
on my Spotify so I've been listening to
it but just hearing it in soul cycle it
was just energy inspired and then she
has this whole album that came out today
the gift which is a whole Lion King
album which I don't want to listen to
any of the music I've seen the movie I
did the same with greatest showmen but I
I love a remake of a classic I did the
same with the reddish omen but I did see
dear Ivan Hansen knowing waving through
a window and it really made the
experience really premium then I fell in
love with so many of the other songs so
I feel like I had a good experience yes
and I think we know the Lion King song
so it'll be great but I want to see I
want to experience them for the first
time like the way that you're meant to
may I take a brief moment to apologize
to my sister Margo because you tried to
get me on the train and I truly slept
and I've only recently come to terms of
the fact like been pot and his album are
literally everything I can't believe we
miss him at the Beacon Theatre like I
watch me this and him like I literally
just crying well we tried to go they
were the tickets were out of control
okay I mean he's literally like the the
Pro freeze the Josh Groban of our
generation I agree cut it he's so
talented in case you live forever grow
as we go like older like I just like I
listen to the album so much house
weekend is what I was traveling and I
just really like I have a say I'm sorry
it's like you push me what listen to it
and I told you to [ __ ] off and I was
wrong no it's he's amazing that album is
like a treasure trove and it looks like
his live show is just so beautiful like
it's no [ __ ] it's his beautiful set
and he just [ __ ] sings and all you
want him to do you have to listen out on
the song in case you don't live forever
and listen to the world course it back
to it it's about his dad like his
parents don't live forever just know
that like I [ __ ] love you and it was
just like he's so like in touch with
like his emotions and like but like the
greater picture of the world like all
the songs like written from like a nine
year old man's perspective really it's
so interesting like he really is like
this wise kid because he's like lived a
million lives like being a child actor
like having like this huge run on
Broadway like he's lived and also just
being like a struggling actor who can't
get a job like yeah lived so many lives
like his music is so mature yeah good
thing it's like David Foster in older
like he talks about he was walking down
57th Street towards parking and old man
go over to him and it's just like this
what the old man said yeah yeah that
song I know but you guys are giving me
rave reviews I mean it's you know sounds
like that's what I need yes Jackie it's
that's exactly what it is it's just what
we need right
and it sounds meaningful I feel like
everything I listen to or watch is
meaningless sometimes I like it that way
but I could go for some meanings yeah
also talk about something
an interesting fact that cardi could
make me cry and play though yeah it is
going to make I have to turn a song off
this morning
wait that I couldn't stop crying this
morning I'm showing my mascara and I was
crying and it was such a sad song and i
bleedin you murder cuz I listened to
your start playlist what song is it
ensign yeah it's brand-new I was
listening to your playlist and I was
loving than know you and grammar the
found you I found you is beautiful I am
yours I am yours I literally had to turn
off our hats try to integrate the grand
oh I had tits my eyes I had to turn it
off but it's a beautiful song it was
just making me so sad like I don't know
why like I really was feeling attached
so here is a race I thought you're the
best part of me with a cheering because
no but that was a really sweet song it
actually came on like right after that
so maybe you were just like in it in a
tizzy get her in it but it's that was
like a really like really lovely song
and II grandma's new music deserves such
such credit oh my god I found you is the
most amazing song like I just can't stop
like I'm always like aside from The Lion
King no today's new music Friday is
garbage well yeah Barbra Arnage cuz you
have like six like literally like six
weeks of like hardcore releases I need a
break
yeah like I was looking at the feed and
I didn't recognize anything oh yes it
was just I felt old did you see new pics
of Camilla Kibeho and tremendous like
out about more restaurants just like
being themselves yeah yeah I'm so here
for oh my I won't talk about something
this should have been a story nikka
priyanka went out for their anniversary
last birthday her birthday and she wore
high heels in a red dress and on her
Instagram story she played the song and
he was filming her in her high heels for
a dress that's really keen that's your
dream yeah yeah
and that I love that oh and the ten year
anniversary of wizards on deck with
Hannah Montana oh yes what is stark what
a historic week it's like what's
happening now that will like have an
anniversary for the heat wave in the
block
you know like descendants comes out
August 2nd yeah I'm not here no but we
have to you can't watch me that I swear
I won't but okay imagine you know the
Bayeux and shamaness I got married that
would just be like a real and her name
is kamila Mendez Oh am i there red she
would be very confusing it's like if
Camille Mendez and Reggie got married at
the same time yeah they would have to
fight for the Zola website totally how
funny is that I can't leave her name
would be Camille minutes it's crazy I
know but if anyone can figure out you
know the intricacies its Scylla the
complexities of to kamila Mendez
situation this is not the first time
that Zola has had this problem I love
Zola joined 500,000 couples who have
used Zola it takes the stress out of
wedding planning with free wedding
websites your dream wedding registry
affordable save the dates and
invitations and easy easy to use
planning tools conveniently manage
everything online and in one place it
saves so much time for couples it takes
the hard part out if like a building a
website like what do I look like an IT
manager like I know how to build a
website
Jackie Zola for her wedding registry and
it was the most jealous I've ever been
because it was so seamless so organized
that thank-you notes like everything was
really clean and for my wedding website
like I looks like I T know like you're
an influencer that like you need to have
a legit wedding website yeah is the only
place that you could have done it no and
like it was just everything was like
ilyich heart like just like you can have
used their pre-made designs you can do
your own thing I just love that I love
freedom yeah you can easy to personalize
your favorite design with all your
wedding details so you can add elements
for your flowers from your invitation so
there's like a cohesive and RG like a
mood board you can add photos stories
about how you met traveling the
commutation info I find that wedding
websites for destination weddings are
literally the most important thing in
the world unbelievably I find myself
screenshotting like all the details like
a freak totally to start your free
wedding website go to Zola calm slash
toast and get an extra $50 off your
registry so again that Zola dot-com
slash toast vol a.com slash toast and a
get $50 off your first registry after
you get a free wedding website Zola
dot-com slash toast can't recommend it
enough Jackie is yet and it should
supreme experience yeah and still being
premium cuz I'm still like having to
reference it you know oh that's so
annoying and by the way when you hear
the word reference what do you think
Lady Gaga to reference or not reference
so that'll be great okay now we need to
recap Real Housewives of New York
because he didn't do last week and this
weekend we're just gonna do the whole
shebang
I'm feeling really conflicted because I
always feel like in my housewife like
feelings I feel very you know concrete
and I've kind of been shook up because
you know I'm a ride-or-die Bethenny san
but like she's being like a little a
little much for me like she's on the
right side of history and like everyone
is kissing her ass now and like on her
side during de is so far up her ass and
like she didn't had the opposite of that
last season like he everyone capered so
she's getting a little comfortable like
being the big dog in town and I just
don't like how kind of um I don't know
what the right word is it's that kind of
setting it's Cavalier like she's just
all of her face like I was loving her
facial expressions the first week and
now it's like she's being like a little
too high on her horse for me um which is
sad because I like love ride-or-die for
her and I still like believe in her and
everything she does um but I want to
talk about Andy because is it just me or
is he like hyper involved only when it
comes to Ramona I've never been more
certain in my life that Ramona's not
coming back because Annie like appears
to [ __ ] hate her really he was
pointing out inconsistencies like so
obvious like usually like he only steps
in when it's like absolutely necessary
or the person's not really understanding
what all the other women are saying like
he was getting so involved only when it
came to Ramona and I've like never been
more sure that she's not a housewife
anymore
oh I didn't feel that way I just felt
like there were so many clear examples
of Ramona like up on her [ __ ] and I
think the viewers really wanted to know
what the hell was going on through her
head and by the way when it comes to
table 61 and 62 and I had set it at the
time when she definitely like just her
61 and 62 are the same to her oh great
and I don't think it was a malicious
thing okay um the thing with the
birthday dinner is different I don't
know what I believe but like that's what
makes Ramona like great and hilarious
yes and like her and Sonja are great
friends and I don't think that there's
any like beef there I think Ramona is
coming back for sure I don't know I feel
really really I feel bad I feel worried
fortunately I was also just watching the
reunions thinking if any one of these
women like I felt the way about about
Sonja about Tinsley and about Ramona
that if one of them didn't come back
like the the storyline would be fine
like Sonja's so out of the conversation
out of the loop
this entire season like I was like damn
where has she been and I felt the same
way about Ramona
not Tinsley like chances at the center
of it but like nobody likes her yet
nobody wants her to be I think nobody
gets and everyone's like we want to hear
more from you then she talks and they're
like shut up yeah I felt bad for they
were coming so hard on her like it's not
their [ __ ] business it's not I I was
glad that we got like I do want to get
to know her two more and we've been
saying this and I think if given the
chance next season would be her to like
her time to blossom like it would be I
would want a Scott list season we do
Vince Lee on her own and give her one
more chance because she needed two or
three years or whatever it was to come
out of her shell but very interesting is
that she moved out of the apartment the
second they stopped filming and moved
back in like she doesn't live in New
York yeah but she it she like it's like
I understand her struggle like she has
no reason to live in New York
other than the show in the show
literally like saved her life but her
mom lives in Florida her boyfriend at
the time lives in Chicago she really has
no other reason to be in New York when
they're not filming so but it's like in
order to be a part of this show like you
have the only requirement is Ike you
have to be in New York yeah I'm like
that's the one thing she like doesn't
want to do or mean like maybe she'd be
better off I mean actually no she lived
in Palm Beach and she got arrested maybe
New York is good for her she's like well
and I felt like any kind of had her back
when talking about the like debutante
thing or maybe just trying to make
Bethenny see like don't insult an entire
like culture of people just cuz you
don't understand it no but she wasn't
insulting it she was saying that it's
not an excuse but I think that it isn't
it no she was saying it's setting back
feminism like you gonna be a debutante
of me a feminists like I don't believe
that you know what I mean she was just
like she was declassifying an entire
group of people on the way that like an
entire group of people like raised their
kids just because it's not how she was
raised like started go to high school in
Atlanta it's not the same as being a
debutante in like Charleston in Richmond
Virginia I don't I mean I just thought
that was a very dismissive of Bethenny
and I didn't like that yeah and that is
how she is so like just figure it out I
think definitely Tinsley's way of you
know her thinking of her life you know
she needs a man a man man man she's
gonna Rob Parham it's cool it's
old-school but there's plenty of people
that are like that's Dylan and then she
brings a different flavor to the I'm
sorry I hope yes and I love Bethenny but
women who say and like judge other women
and say that they're setting back
feminism to entire what is 100 years
like no no women who say that about
other women you're set
back feminism I don't care if you
tinsley like thinks that she needs a man
that's kind of life like I hate like the
version of feminism where it's like you
judge other women there's like a elitism
like oh I am a CEO so I'm better than
right who works at our house like no or
Adam that are gonna stay at home ah like
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] so I I don't
like when people say like so-and-so or
this type of woman it sets back feminism
no women you judge other women you set
us back no in feminism is women being
able to choose what they want to do
whether that is to work or to not work
or whether that's not what Bethenny
would agree with it's like I love
Bethenny and I was just like not
agreeing with her like like a hundred
percent which is hard for me because
usually I'm like ride-or-die apologist
yeah I know I I was she wasn't bothering
me um except that I felt with Ramona
it's hard because what she said was so
terrible but she's so oh my Arabic like
what can you do beyond that you know
yeah and she said she called Bethenny
she called his family he said everything
I know she's the apologizer but she
really said everything right like I
apologize I apologized to God I
apologize to everyone I houses to God
like she's like a two-year-old like she
really couldn't have felt worse about it
and I know she'll probably like do more
things in the future
they were just digging in a little bit
when she already felt terribly you know
Bethenny was a Bethenny was doing the
thing that she accused LuAnn of doing
when LuAnn and Dorinda made up in the
Berkshires LuAnn Bethenny said like
LuAnn you were like relishing in during
this apology and like that's kind of
what she was doing to Ramona at the
Reunion but she had the right to she had
yes also Bethenny always brings up the
bridge and you know you'll never find
happiness or remember when they were on
the Brooklyn Bridge and remember like
ten years ago
that was the second now the second most
awful thing do Ramona's ever surprise me
but remember when they were in the pool
in Mexico naked crying apologizing at
what point is that apology like clink it
clear the slate I don't like I thought
at that point that everything in the
past we're not gonna forget about it but
we're gonna move on from it and now it's
here going forward and like Bethenny
saying that like Ramona has something
out for her I think Ramona's the same
with Bethenny issues with everyone just
like annoying
a little mean and by the way that Amina
that's housewives in general it's like
an apology is made and it never exists
ever other than in that moment yeah even
Dorinda and
they made up they she went over to hug
and they're still fighting yeah well
they have to rehash stuff but I think
Bethenny bringing up the bridge it's
like that is so long ago I really it was
a difference the bridge on this yeah yes
she quoted something that Ramona said to
her on that bridge which was like you'll
never like be like oh I have no friends
I guess it's old but isn't it crazy how
like certain things like stick with you
yeah like I'm sure people have said like
mean things about me but like random
ones like stick with me yeah and I don't
know why but it's really interesting
like what you remember like what stays
with you and how like some of these
women can get past like the worst [ __ ]
ever but they'll never forget what you
said to them on the Brooklyn Bridge
right and it's just like how Ramona
walked out and out some accord was
talking about her nude photos like
that's not the same Ramona we have today
and that's the same Ramona who was on
the bridge like so people really do
change she obviously is still Romina
sometimes but she's gotten a lot better
which is Bravo has been so pertinent and
these a couple reunions with Beverly
Hills in New York with the flashbacks
yeah because now oh my god because we
did it
Oh nobody to do in the episode now I
keep thinking people were saying that
the Alex McCord nude photos has
something to do with Jeffrey Epstein
that they partied what like and that
that's why they like left the country
and like their disappearance was so
weird remember and that I don't remember
it's blind so now Alex McCord yes and
Simon van Kempen and Jeffery FC yes and
just like the the island of it all oh my
god I don't want to misspeak but there
is a blind about it which kind of made a
lot of sense because they look literally
disappeared from Planet Earth and like
moved to Australia and she became
psychologist yeah and she was the first
month so she always had a character
right but it wouldn't be it wouldn't be
out of character for that thirst monster
that go party with a millionaire like
she thinks like it's cool like she
there's 12 year olds around you know
what I mean but Jill that's all I was
thinking about and by the way the
reunions have come so far in terms of
their day quarter but that reunion was
at the Russian Tea Room which is where
Olivia got married that's crazy
I just loved by the way there if you
want to get married in New York go visit
all the venues they've ever had a real
housewife or Union app because it's
literally just like a perfect where's
this reunion being held capital perfect
alright everyone it's matter looks there
yeah get married it's a bar mitzvah
central yeah
also when Ramona was saying the mother I
think they've done it there before I
think they're not dipping back in
there's so few venues in New York yeah
but also cabbie hell is perfect like
they could do it there every year and by
the way who was it that told us that
and every reunion set is based off of
the location in which they took a trip
Erika Jayne and it's true because now
I'm thinking the whole vibe is very
Miami there's a Cabana behind Andy think
about it or so dia had a meltdown
yeah and that was such an interesting
fact she told us yeah the reunion like
the theme of the day Court is in line
with where they took its mix tired by
the trip yes is like white linen so
Beverly Hills right now she said it
would be France is it did the readings
start yeah I remember it's very bright
out there you know but I have to look
around like I was looking for details
there was a mock like ice bucket with a
bunch of bottles of champagne which is
like so Miami they did a good job for
the New York one oh that's so cool when
Ramona said that she drinks like the
millenniums like that's why we need
Ramona millenniums Ben was dying oh my
god good morning millenniums she's she's
really a gem she is and it's like I've
always just I've never been her biggest
fan ever but this is the time that I
dislike her the least and he's getting
the most heat and by the way she's
always one till I come for Andy when
Andy's coming for her like members she
was like well I don't ask who you have
sex with it's like I'm not on a [ __ ]
reality show like they have been Choa
Choa and i wonder why she didn't like
react to the fact that Andy was very
obviously coming for her like I think
she just like knew she needed to ride
the wave and when it was over I
literally felt like okay Ramona it's
like her pit is solved like who's next
you know by the way they kept like
showing commercials for Barbara thought
she was gonna be on Sep so but she's not
till next week no and she says something
that they keep repeating a night I can't
make out what she's what she said she
said something to win like she calls or
something and I'm like I don't know what
you're saying I don't know what the word
is but yes so like when Bethenny comes
and takes her spray tan off like that's
not cool
let's you spend all their sewing
tomorrow and win me they're so mean when
you're in this like there's a big turn a
big fat turn up what like how can you
say that I know but I want to go back to
the spray tan thing because that's the
issue I'm having with Bethenny like who
do you think you are like literally if
someone did that to your face like you
spent all day getting ready for the you
knew you're coming over here with a
napkin yeah don't Joe [ __ ] touch my
spray Chan yeah
also Ramona's saying that she didn't
want her birthday party filmed and
that's why she didn't bite Sonja I don't
totally believe her but then Andy's
saying to her but you're on a reality
show like you've to open up your life
like Ramona has opened up her life
plenty plenty like
I thought that was just like that's what
you say the [ __ ] like Lala Ken you
know you don't say that to Ramona Singer
the og movers who got divorced on the
show yeah embarrassed herself more on
the show than anyone rude because she
didn't want to have her birthday dinner
filmed even though I don't I think that
that was a lie but that wasn't the
proper response to that statement
because she's open I just find any being
so involved like when when she was
talking when LuAnn was talking about how
everyone was texting her about tickets
she said it's a show today like I'm busy
and he's like I mean I performed at the
weekend with Anderson Cooper and
everyone was texting me for tickets like
he's just so talky you know what I mean
yeah I think maybe he feels most
comfortable with these women and I'm
sure he's gone like you score reports
that are like the fans like when Andy
holds the women account I do because
sometimes we're all at home thinking
something and no one says it and it
never gets answered but if Andy knows
that this is probably like the logical
next response he'll just say it so that
people can feel satiated yeah when they
did the flashback to the Russian to your
mounts McCord moment and Andy looked so
different it's like all the women let's
everybody says Andy yeah he's hot yeah
when he did if I strike out much what
happens live with getting al saud to the
first ever episode and it was just like
so weird power of Danielle stabbed like
literally launched an empire
totally and it's also was just a 10-year
anniversary of watch outside we're just
coming upon so many anniversaries
exactly like it's really been like a
good 10 years that I've now been like a
part of pop culture in the sense that
like I know about it yeah like so what
happened in a year like in 2020 so
coming up I will have started college
ten years ago Wow yeah well we're so
graduated high school I feel when I was
in high school like we always had so
much homework that I couldn't watch that
much TV no and like the world wedding
was like my the thing that I cloned my
hat to and like I would literally start
up till 5:00 in the morning like I was
just that was the only thing I would
grow to die for yeah also loves the
Kardashians and Jersey Shore yes
loved by the way a show to restart and
watch the Jersey Shore I did it and I
went all the way up to season four and I
never got back to six but that season
when they go from Florence straight to
the Jersey Shore like that's where I
lost touch it is an excellent show and I
know you didn't really watch when you
were a kid Margo and I think you would
really like it yeah it's it's good we I
want for nothing like it's it's every it
has everything it has everything it's
really good
it's like trash it's love there's
romance it's great it's great so for
next season what we sold one more
episode of reunion but I feel like
Tinsley
they she's out of the woods on whatever
heat so like how do you think she's
gonna be back honestly this was like not
a great season and I think I think it's
time for a shake-up but I don't know if
the newest girl is the shake-up factor
you know I mean yeah quotient quotient
also I just have to say like I know I
said this last week but I totally get
the love of during that like I'm I love
her like I love how she's like clinging
to Bethenny's side she's finally on the
right side of history she's finally in a
good clear mental state she's making a
lot of sense she's not sorry her words
like I get why everyone's been obsessed
with her yes she's a little hard on
tensely for my liking randomly when
they're not really that close we had you
hear anything on the one hand gently
like we want to see more of her we want
her to open up but like she does and
she's crying in the [ __ ] clown outfit
and like that was so embarrassing like
she's opening you know like but then
it's like not enough for people it's not
enough because it all seems so stupid
yeah but like that's who she is she's
stupid
like like when Ramona does it it's great
TV when Tinsley does it it's like at
this child off my screen it's like a
little pathetic but yeah that's who she
is okay she just don't like who she is
maybe maybe maybe that's it maybe I
maybe I don't like I think she deserves
one more season but I do think we need a
new was person who's not a Barbara
agreed they need one of Ramona's like
socialite friends and they need to just
shell out the dollars to pay for it
because those real rich women of New
York didn't wanna be on the show but
they don't want to sully their names
like they're not gonna bring drama they
just want to float through if even if
they do it they'll just float through
they needs me someone who's clamoring to
get back Jill Zarin
oh of course I mean that would be so
easy I wonder why they haven't done that
yeah I feel like a lot of the
franchise's now it's bins like 1012
years where it'd be good but like the
answer is to go back yeah interesting
just an interesting theory okay
well this is our final episode of the
week and before our official summer
break hiatus we are back on the air
Monday August 5th
yes my song will be out by then but we
will be up on Instagram we will be up on
everything will be up on patreon there's
a lot going on maybe mitla Margo now
which is like hop in the studio do an
episode if we're around yeah like if I
was thinking that every time that you
on hate is something crazy happening
yeah always so we'll see yes next week
that's great because we did it this show
today and there's [ __ ] nothing
happening by the time we get back love
what to talk about next week I am
working I'm in Montreal for a show and
Charleston the Montrell show is sold out
but the Charleston show has a bunch of
tickets left so head to girl John job
comm so next week that will be in the
show so we got to that maybe tomorrow
and I'm feeling inspired to there's like
breaking news we will come into the
studio drop an episode sweet we have
three more patreon episodes coming this
month so if you need content and discern
a concise and morning toast if you join
picture on now you get access to all of
the previous episodes that is like
what's five Whedon 1270 episodes and I
went back and watch some of our old vlog
episodes and I was like hysterically
laughing uh ya know our behind the
scenes are just award-winning
documentaries and there's so much for
you to choose from so thank you guys so
much for your viewership your love and
just stream a toast August 2nd oh my god
I'm so excited
and um head to Jackie O flow comm to get
your summer presets that your flow I
must bond and pop in the premium and
smoke I'm so excited to use and I
literally made them so I didn't have to
like make the presets while I'm on
vacation like in their pre-made sets so
we will see in two weeks
it says they love you
you